So here is your mini project. We want you to
create your very own secret message, for a friend, or a
loved one. Now, the secret message could be anything from
you wishing them a great day to you telling them how
happy you are to have them in your life. You
can start by showing them the jumbled up version of your
message. Now, we have provided some images of the alphabet
in the instructor notes. You can use them if you'd like.
Then run the program and reveal your secret message
to your friend. Your assignment is to share videos or
photos of your friend's reaction with us on the discussion
forum. Once you're done, check this box before you continue.